more than a dozen parents in the college
admissions scandal have agreed to plead
guilty now they're waiting to learn if
they face prison time one of them is
actress Felicity Huffman in her first
public comments since her arrest Huffman
said yesterday that she feels quote deep
regret and shame she's accused of
spending fifteen thousand dollars to
boost her daughter's SAT score Carter
Evans is at the University of Southern
California in Los Angeles Carter good
morning good morning
actress Lori Laughlin is not one of
those parents that's working with
prosecutors she allegedly spent half a
million dollars to get her daughter's
into USC but experts are now saying the
plea deals on Monday are putting
pressure on Laughlin and others who have
yet to cooperate just days after
appearing in a Boston federal courtroom
actress Felicity Huffman admitted her
guilt in the nation's largest College
Admission scandal in a statement the 56
year old said I accept full
responsibility for my actions and will
accept the consequences my daughter knew
absolutely nothing and in my misguided
and profoundly wrong way I have betrayed
her as part of Huffman's plea deal
prosecutors are advising a prison term
at the low end of the sentencing
guidelines of four to ten months she's
also agreed to pay a twenty thousand
dollar fine Felicity Huffman pleading
guilty and giving such a perfect
statement of remorse and contrition is a
very bad sign for Lori Loughlin if you
go forward and fight this case you
really could wind up with a sentence
that is a lot of time in prison the 13
parents pleading guilty are accused of
cheating or using bribes to help
guarantee their children's admission
into college including Stanford which
has confirmed it expelled a student
whose application was linked to the
scandal what we don't know is what the
government is going to do about some of
the students because some of the
students knew exactly what their parents
were doing among the parents agreeing to
plead guilty real estate developer Bruce
Isaacson and his wife Davina who
admitted paying more than a
million dollars in facebook stock to
bribe a soccer coach to get their
daughter into UCLA in a statement the
isaacsohn said they were profoundly
sorry adding our duty as parents was to
set a good example for our children and
instead we have harmed and embarrassed
them by our misguided decisions by
having these guilty pleas all at one
time it's to send a message out there to
the remaining defendants that you better
get in here and you better get in here
quick
now the 13 defendants are going to have
to return to Boston to formally enter
their guilty pleas a source with
knowledge of the investigation says
there are dozens of other parents under
investigation in California alone who
have not been named publicly Gail Thank
You Carter I think some of the parents
need to call Rikki Kleeman her her
observations quite often or always to me
seem to be so on point and I have to say
to Felicity Huffman to to own it to
apologize and express deep deep deep
remorse obsession I can't think of
anything worse as a parent than
embarrassing your children yeah but then
the second lesson accepting
responsibility exactly I blame you and
she owned it and apologized and on the
other hand here's Laurie Lachlan who's
out taking pictures and signing
autographs outside the court proceedings
I don't know if that sends the right
message the story continues as you know
Carter we thank you again